[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
my older sister i have an older sister
and a younger my older sister your
sister is 92 92 years old wild it's
crazy yeah we're born so far apart um
but she uh she has been the
per the person at fault
in
13 or 14 car accidents what yeah take
her license away i know that's it what
state is this in
a few but mostly in wisconsin in florida
she's a national problem on the road
she's it's
unbelievable time out let me ask them
not to cut you off yeah in wisconsin
there isn't a three-strike loss so maybe
that's why she because you know that's
where she started driving okay because
because i don't know if you know this
this is we used to joke about this in
chicago wisconsin has no law it's in dui
culture if you get three steve duis you
have a license uh your license is
expelled for the rest of your life right
yeah well three strike law states
california yeah yeah most places that
are like that yeah if you have three
three duis you're done for doc yeah
wisconsin does not have a three strike
law for duis there was a woman
sorry to interject but there was a woman
i remember reading a story she had 12
duis i've always heard those stories but
wisconsin because wisconsin cops are
like come on betty get home will you and
she's like alright you get it at home
they're like
wow she's gotta take you in come on we
got will you follow us will you follow
us can you like wisconsin has that like
drinking
country lifestyle where they're like
falls asleep
we gotta take her in every guy in comedy
has a small penis or smallish penis how
about that or is unaware
that it's not small if it isn't
that's so true yeah actually i found out
that i found out how medium penised i am
and i made me so happy
like in in high school
like high school is when you find out if
you have a small penis a big penis or a
medium penis yeah and it was nice
because i played sports and then you see
other penises and you go okay bigger
bigger smaller same same smaller same
you know i mean i had a lot of i had two
pro athletes
and i played sports yeah dude my high
school like pushed out pro athletes wow
two brothers that both played in the nfl
big dicks
i mean absurd you knew that they knew
but you also at some point and i was the
first one to make a joke about it i'd be
like put on you wear a towel like yeah
he would walk around after we showered
and chat with people yeah yeah where are
you going tonight and you're like come
on will you yeah same same same i
showered with clothes on
we did too yeah and and there was a guy
who would also showers are done yeah and
he had a he had a thigh slapper yeah and
he would just go around be like oh did
you guys see him we're like dude come on
he's like yo that last play and you're
like hanging that's banging on
we're like all right have you ever
witnessed a surgery
um
no no have you
many really yeah i had the wild idea
that i wanted to be a doctor a surgeon
you did well this is young though yeah
sure sure so i was like a freshman in
high school
and i tell i'm like i think i want to be
a doctor
i mean i'm a freshman aren't your
parents like come on yeah of course but
i think they're like well this is a good
sign it's a good sign but also like he's
[ __ ] dumb he's not gonna do he can't
get but i was like yes i do i mean i'm
very convincing you know and they're
like okay
so
i go i think i want to be like a surgeon
though you know so yeah
my dad
calls his brother who's like a
well-known doctor who sets me up is your
dad a doctor by the way no okay his
brother
and uh
sets me up to go to the mayo in
jacksonville
and witness
surgery
like for a day to just be a part of it
like i get there seven a.m
and i'm a freshman i remember that the
one of the doctors goes what school do
you go to i was a kind of a big kid you
know yeah
i mean for a freshman in high school i
was probably uh
i don't know five nine five ten and like
185 or something
full size and he was like what school do
you go to and i i say my high school and
he's like
that's a university and i go i'm in high
school he was like you're in high school
so i think he thought he was also eating
the other high school boys well he's
like he goes like
why are you like he thought he was going
to take like a college kid right right
right and he's like so you're here i was
like i want to do this
and he was like
okay all right
so i witnessed
13
surgeries that day holy [ __ ] they start
me like
first day like i'm at the hospital
6 30 in the morning yeah and this guy
he's like all right and he takes me in
like the first surgery we witness
is to an 87 year old woman
who's having a cyst removed from her
vagina oh my god and
i go in there and he's like you're gonna
stand here he goes
like so i'm standing
at the foot of the bed and you're
standing in like a sudden
staring straight up yeah yeah i'm
covered and everything and he goes uh go
come here come here and he pulls me
aside he goes just so you know she's not
under so if you say something she can
hear it and i go she's awake for the
surgery yeah she's just like
anesthetized ah right right from the
below the waist
do they start and like so there's this
87 year old [ __ ] just like wide open in
front of me i'm like all right that's
how you knew you were gay i knew i knew
it
and then he kind of he's like they go in
there and then he
he's like here's the cyst and then he's
like holy [ __ ] like this is enormous so
they start bringing in other people to
look at it
and then they go like edith and she's
like yes he goes we're gonna take some
pictures
and she's like
okay we just want to post this stuff on
myspace this is wild we've never seen
one this size
so this is going to be in a journal
but your face won't be in the photos or
anything like that okay she just gives
like a rock on above it yeah [ __ ] yeah
and so they start taking pictures and
i'm sitting there like oh my god and
then he pops it and
yeah it's just like oozing oh my god you
believe that and he was like what not
something and i go yeah
yeah i'm gonna get into stand-up comedy
yeah
there's male etiquette to to bathroom
stuff that women don't have to worry
about is when you walk in yesterday i
was walking i was in the urinal
i took the furthest one
and of course a guy went just one too
close to me but there was one right next
to the sink that he could have taken
and it's impossible
to not look as a guy if you're if you're
finishing to turn you're gonna see it
yeah okay you're gonna see it and
i saw it
and it was huge and i was like he wanted
me to see it he wanted you he got close
for you to see it he wanted me to see it
yeah and so what did i do to him i
pulled my back out and i go are you
happy now yeah fine
and i put it back away i put it right
back into my balls don't you hate when
you're at a urinal and you feel like you
don't have like good like length at the
moment oh flying yeah and you're like
i'm just gonna like
just in case someone walks in i'm gonna
give it a little tug right now oh i
shake yeah i'll do a little waggle
around let's get a little blood going
right yeah
well i p what i do is i pull up the head
and i smack it yeah i'll you just pull
it up
yeah right underneath just get it going
yeah it'll start to really move and get
thick yeah yeah it's a good time
and i know internally they probably talk
[ __ ] to each other like what are you
doing is like a
podiatrist or an orthopedist and they're
like oh
like do they [ __ ] on each other
absolutely so like if you do if you're
if you're a surgeon
they're like top top tier [ __ ] and they
look at the other doctors like [ __ ]
like oh is that you they absolutely do
that's so funny
general surgeons i'm saying are up there
uh cardio like heart surgeons that's
legit neurologists right you know you're
doing like who's the lowest like who's
the one they mock the most well i mean
i'm sure it's probably chiropractors you
know
but then
even if you're gonna fix his back they
might yeah i mean they're like you're
not but i mean i'm sure they they
definitely all if you're like you know
your general physician they realize that
you're you're a necessity yeah you're
needed but they're like
they they are what are you really
they're like you know that they call
them wikipedia way above you yeah
then here comes dr wikipedia with his
[ __ ] with his generalized
are you going to guess what someone has
again mike is that what you're going to
do so your whole thing is that you refer
your patients to us
so it's i mean it's exciting man no i'm
excited for you guys it is it is cool i
would dare you to not see rogan or talk
to him the whole time that you're there
that'd be hilarious how fun you guys
move there for i feel like and then in
like 20 30 i'm like do you live here too
have you seen what he's doing down there
his club and all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's pretty incredible huh
yeah [ __ ] wild i mean good
good building rebuilding the universe i
mean it's just got it's it has to be
somewhere it's it's cool if that place
becomes an epicenter of comedy i know so
many people moving there yeah
i can't no
we just bought this house and i i have
almost no money so at this point i can't
do it i just gotta like you know
the only way is if
you know
no i yeah i'd be so hard it'd be so hard
to do also you know i've got the podcast
with noodles and like what am i gonna do
with that
yeah do you know what i mean like he's
not he can't leave here
dude it would be awesome
if you moved there
and just started it with just any
korean guy like a random korean guy yeah
and it was just bad for and you never
said anything yeah it would piss him off
you just got to know him on the podcast
and it became a huge hit they're like
these guys are the [ __ ] i just steal
them i steal everything from the studio
it's all bad friend stuff yeah do you
want to call you bob he's like okay he's
like fine for me doctors treat nurses
the way
from just what i've heard you treat
everyone that's ever opened for you oh
i'm you you are brutal you're brutal
somebody told me one time whoever was
opening for you a couple of years ago
not only did you not they couldn't get a
hotel you forced them to uh you rented a
car at hertz you rented like a chevy
volt and you made them sleep in the car
i did and i also you wouldn't turn it on
no i don't turn it on no
because it's about you know getting like
i realize i'm a coach for these
you know openers what were you going to
see where you say [ __ ] well i was
just saying
i also asked for a feature gift
so they have to bring you to bring me a
gift and so the first time
that i you know i was educating one of
them on it and they were like what's a
feature gift and i'm like well
you get the headliner
as a way of saying you know thank you
for having me and she the opener was
like well how do i like how much did i
spend
and i go how much are you earning this
week right so she said you know
five hundred dollars
something around five hundred dollars
five to six hundred dollars yeah it
should be they should be willing to take
a loss to open for you yeah of course
financially
because i have heard what you typically
do is if a feature is getting a certain
amount of money let's just make an
arbitrary and let's just say like oh
they get 700
i've heard that you dock depending on
what how many jokes you don't like yeah
that's true oh yeah if like i go if you
don't open strong right so is it how how
do you dock is it 10 i don't want
anything
if you have a wildlife joke you
immediately lose 100 bucks really so
it's out out and what's the biggest
detrimental what joe can they tell that
you really take away the most money what
is it that that's like the thing that
they just to inform listeners in case
they don't know
that you really start taking away money
if they do a certain kind of joke or
yeah i mean like if they do an accent or
like
you know something about like oh you
know one time i i was with my mom and
you know family stuff yeah yeah you know
you really cut it then it's then they
just go right to half yeah have you ever
made sure that people that work with you
don't get paid at all
i try to like i'll you know if i do if i
do a club i'll just i'll tell the club
i'll go are you planning on paying them
and they'll be like yeah i'll go just
give it to me
you know yeah
and then they go like you'll pay them
and i go
yeah
yeah i'll pay them it's not for the
minority and speak of which uh tom is
doing shows for minorities uh you're
doing spanish-speaking only shows you're
doing poc shows uh are white's allowed
to go
they can you don't
prefer it right i understand that will
you sell are ticket prices higher for
whites after you get seated we do a
collection right you know how fun that
would be honestly i would [ __ ] love
to do you know that in today's world
everybody would be like okay yeah that's
what i'm saying though that's how [ __ ]
up we are that like i would love to do a
show where black people have a ticket
price that's one
latin people love it
asian people and white people have to
pay like a super premium yeah they're
like as soon as you're like if you're
white you walk in like and it's five
hundred dollars what but you know whites
are like well we'll put it on the card i
mean it is worth the show just geez we
love tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]